good morning Hank it's Tuesday so our
dog Willie is probably near the end of
his life and I don't want to wait until
he dies to Uwe gize him so here goes
fireball Wilson Roberts green came home
with us in 2008 he was named for the
alcoholic bulldog in James Crummles
novel the last good kiss but we called
him Willie because as the vet put it
he's Willie Willie cute because he is
cute I expected Willie to be a cuddly
furball snuggly puppy but Willie does
not cuddle or at least he didn't until
the last few months he is a very
strong-willed dog at times exhaustingly
so he does not want your pity and he
does not want your baby talk he does
want your food especially bacon and
peanut butter but not so much that he'll
put up with your stupid human BS like
when our children were smaller they
would run around the house holding dog
treats trying to get Willie to chase
them and he would for a while but then
he would stop and go over to his dog bed
and wait for the kids to walk to him and
feed him and then after eating the
treats he would dash away returning the
world to its normal order people running
after him speaking of kids because
Willie would not generally be classified
as like a sweet dog we worried a lot
about new additions to our family like
how would Willie handle the sudden
presence of a human child and then two
children taking up so much of the
attention we had once lavished upon him
brilliantly as it turned out Willie has
always been extraordinarily gentle and
patient with our kids even when they
were babies there is nothing calm about
the way Willie responds to anything
except when it comes to kids and in turn
our children are fiercely loyal to him
anytime Sara or I say in conversation
that we're a family of four the kids
both shout back no five you forget about
Willie and I say well but for humans and
they say but five family members and
they're right Willie is only a dog and I
recognize that but he's our dog and we
are for at least a little while longer
a family of five when we first brought
Willie home I talked about him a lot on
the internet but over the years as I
began to value the privateness of my
private life more he became less of a
fixture of my online life but he has
been a constant in our family
amid big changes and for me personally
even though his barking has ruined
thousands of vlog brothers takes his
companionship has been a profound gift
especially in hard times one of the
challenging things about my mental
illness is how isolating it can be
my obsessive fears and worries seemed to
other people wildly irrational because I
suppose from an objective standpoint
they are wildly irrational and that can
make those fears difficult to share like
nobody can really take my fear that X
terrible thing is about to happen
seriously because they don't find my
obsessive reasoning compelling but that
doesn't help me because I find my
obsessive thoughts incredibly compelling
and then there's the problem of not even
wanting to talk about X for fear that
talking about it will make X happen
which is why I'm currently referring to
it as X and so you end up in this spiral
of thought feeling very alone because
people can love you and they can listen
to you but they cannot share this
feeling because they know it to be
irrational but Willy doesn't know all he
knows is that I'm scared I want to be
careful not to anthropomorphize Willy he
is not a person and I don't know what
life is like for him but I do believe
after 10 years together that he knows
when I'm worried he knows when I am
consumed by thoughts I cannot shake and
in those moments he gravitates to me no
cuddling of course but he will lay at my
feet or walk around in circles to tell
me that it is time to play together he
takes me seriously in a way that no
human can and I'm grateful for that
Willy is harder to take care of these
days and weeks have interrupted sleep
have piled up on all of us but still I
am grateful to him as the cancer
advances in Willy becomes the quiet
chill cuddly dog I thought I always
wanted I'm grateful for the dog he is
and also for the stubborn yappy and
loyal dog that he was you're a good dog
Willy and I love you Hank I'll see you
on Friday